a man who does not exercise the body is
feeding the vice of sloth and is thus
sinning okay
uh did you get that I got it all right
yeah I got a land clearer
thanks a lot yes he I mean yes yes of
course but that doesn't mean three hours
in the gym in the morning yeah I heard
that C.S Lewis said a day wasn't
complete without a good walk yeah so if
a good walk is true to the mailbox yes
yeah back good walk is access to the bar
yeah right to The Liquor Cabinet yeah
yes because I do I guess then it's that
last part of the question that trips you
up a little bit I have not exercised in
at least you know 50 years and I'm only
32 years old
but is that I think it's bad I think
it's sloth I think it is a vice
certainly is that a sin that I would be
obligated to confess again no I think it
depends on what you mean by exercise I
really do